on peut toujours réussir via la télé
mais malheureusement ça dépend comment
on a envie de réussir si on a envie de
réussir dans un chemin qui est sain et
avoir des bons projets ou si c'est
seulement s'exposer être l'objet de
l'objet de production c'est tout alors
aujourd'hui tu viens tu va nous raconter
des choses qu'on n'a jamais fait nous de
casting de télé réalité
comme pioneer un tank et et n'a pas fait
de ok maintenant j'ai pas fait de jeu
c'est drôle ils sont je suis dans les
mags dans le maïs et le mag denner
exactement il n'a rien à voir voyez les
candidats tous les jours mais a même un
pacte avec jacques tôt alors comment se
passent les castings et commencer s'est
passé le tir je peux te tutoyer eh bien
c'est dit merci déjà il faut savoir que
quand on est bon à l'époque avant le coc
vide donc on faisait des castings
physiquement accélère pour se présenter
directement et moi en amont m'a dit ok
donc tu vas juste présentés mais ramène
un maillot de bain avec toi où j'ai dit
ok
puissent-ils ou quoi voilà enfin qu'est
ce qui va se passer et j'arrive
obligation première obligation on doit
être célibataire c'est peu importe peu
importe les princes de l'amour ou
d'hôtes deux émissions on doit être
scellé maintenant c'est une obligation
ça ans ça ça comme miss france c'est
vrai on peut à la limite ça je te le dis
qu elin je peux le comprendre parce que
ce qu'ils veulent on va pas se mentir
c'est cette émission c'est des émissions
ou séries marche ce sont les sons les
couples ce sont les voilà un orri de
savoir qui est avec qui s'il va y avoir
des histoires d'amour et c'est donc ça
allait vite ça me choque pas mais c'est
bien mais ça me choque pas ouais moi moi
je trouve ça un peu dérangeant dans le
sens où si certains candidats lyonnais
ça fait dix ans qu'ils sont là d'engrais
ça fait cinq ans ça veut dire que
pendant tout ce temps là t'as pas
vraiment une vie était dépendante du
fait que tu vas devoir rester
célibataires du fait que tu dois te
mettre tout le temps avec des gens de la
télé c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai il y
en a qui sont en couple depuis très
longtemps et qui ont des enfants
maintenant oui aujourd'hui sortie du
milieu n'ont pas tous il y en a encore
regarder mais c'est des gens des
techniques qui sont ensemble de faire il
reste ils sont pas très bons et méchants
mais ce petit jeu que dit khalid sais
que tu es obligé maintenant gras à cause
de ça je compense que jacqueline sais
que tu es obligé de rencontrer quelqu'un
dans ce milieu là ouais donc l'aï donc
c'est un peu c'est comme si moi je vous
dis ici doit lire l'acte akmatov toi tu
arrêtes avec roger
nombreuses femmes
non non oui mais là vous remettez un
plan en question le concept même de la
témérité passe quasi à des émissions
dont c'est le concept d'être célibataire
les princes de l'amour l'appellation il
vous a dit cheikh mon sujet on s'en fout
de ça la nuit persia je pense que c'est
c'est dans des formations ou tout
simplement tu vas faire une compétition
c'est de l'épreuve sportive où est
l'intérêt de se mettre forcément en
couple je vais une question abordée ce
qu'on vous a déjà demandé de vous mettre
avec quelqu'un pour le bien de
l'émission donc oui moi plus à deux
reprises dans deux émissions différentes
donc l'avant dernière et la dernière
donc dans les princes de l'amour quand
j'ai eu mes prétendants on m'a demandé
d'accélérer le pas avec un de mes
prétendants de l'embrasser et des choses
comme ça dans ma dernière mission donc
objectif reste du monde le positif donc
c'était les épreuves sportives les jobs
les frappe intellectuelle
et le producteur à plusieurs reprises la
production à plusieurs reprises m'a dit
rapproche toi d'ailleurs à l'époque
c'était ilan rapproche toi dylan on
aimerait que tu te rapproches dylan etc
wi-lan physiquement ce n'était pas mon
style et voilà je très gentil mais voilà
sans plus donc j'avais pas j'aime pas
forcément envie et donc il me relancer
me relancer morosité c'est bon c'est un
peu lourd quand même et sachant qu'en
plus je faisais de travail j'avais je
suis arrivée première dans les épreuves
sportives deuxième balise et programmes
actuels je me suis dit bon toi bien et
en fait j'ai appris par la suite quand
j'ai été éliminé au premier tour que
c'était à cause de ça parce que je ne
voulais pas faire d'histoires avec des
arceaux
alors ça mathieu on peut le comprendre
ça bah ouais
non non non la station mais moi je vous
parle je parle à matthew booth qui il
vous faisiez le débrief des débats à la
fois on peut pas le comprendre et à la
fois c'est vrai que nous ce qu'on disait
aux jeunes filles qui faisaient les
anges ou qu à l'époque c'est voilà si
vous rentrez dans le jeu voilà vous
savez qu'on est braqué des
rapprochements les petites histoires
d'amour mais si vous voulez pas je mets
un coup mais encore faut quelqu'un le
gars
mais s'il
vise celui là mais souvent c'était bassi
peut y voir une histoire d'amour c'est
mieux et bien sûr une vie c'est ça oui
comment ça s'est passé ça mais c'est
tout droit d'un
maintenant et pardon mais ce ne sont
plus des candidats ce sont des acteurs
ce sont des comédiens ils savent que par
l'anc et l'ina avec tout le respect que
je dois mais vous savez que quand vous
rentrez dans une émission de télévision
parce que précédent les spectateurs ce
n'est pas les jeux ce n'est pas par pecz
audun groenvold
histoire d'amour une piscine et une
histoire d'amour à quelqu'un qui écrit
il ya quelques riffs
image totalement les déclarations de
kelly une candidate de télé réalité m'a
dit la semaine dernière elle m'a raconté
qu'elle était sur une émission que je
peux pas donner le nom elle était sur
une émission la productrice lui avait
dit si tu ne couche pas je donne les
termes exacts ainsi nul ne couche pas on
te met à l'écart et honteux virtu ne
refera plus d'émissions avec vous donc
là ça s'apparente à des pressions qui
sont ce que tu as tu reçu des menaces et
des pressions par écoute oui de l'après
en fait c'est de la manipulation
on quand tu rentres dans le milieu d'eux
dans le milieu de la télé tu rentre dans
un cercle vicieux où forcément tu vas
devenir connus bompas pas forcément tout
le monde va exploser entre guillemets
mais pour mon cas ça a été ça a été ça
donc j'ai dit dès ma première télé j'ai
vite explosé ensuite il ya l'argent l
argent qui est derrière etc il ya
plusieurs choses et en fait tu ne peux
plus être une personne comme tout le
monde le revenu environnement où t'as
mis le pied dans la télé tu es quelqu'un
d'exposer tu es quelqu'un de connu et tu
dois toi même tu as ta vie tu dois la
travailler pour que ce soit ce style de
vie je dois tu dois être une influence
et si tu dois tu dois tu dois avoir
c'est un titre c'est quoi les menaces
que tu sais c'est pas des menaces mais
c'est de la pression c'est
par exemple ce genre de choses où tu
dois faire des histoires tu dois faire
des soirées garçon tu dois t'en brouille
avec certaines personnes parce que sinon
tu n'es pas vu à la télé donc à qu'est
ce que tu fais en télé si tu ne cites on
ne te voit pas c'est cdc dépression
comme ça en fait et même des pressions
vis-à-vis des candidats fins et haïssent
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
manipulations
voilà moi il ya une personne ya une
personne de la production d'ailleurs de
mon dernier tournage elle est venue me
voir elle me dit oh je te trouvais tente
on m'avait vendu du rêve sur toi là je
comprends pas j'étais en moi de bages
fait le chsld ce qu'il faut faire je
comprends pas ouais mais ne rentrent
plus dans le tas va faire des histoires
va faire ça c'est pas moi je ne vais pas
me dénaturer dans un programme jeu le
but quand même de la télé réalité ces
lettres ce qu'on essaie notre
personnalité donc s'ils ne veulent pas
bah ils montent vers de latéralité c'est
vrai que va pas se mentir ce qu'elle dit
c'est tout à fait vrai maintenant il y
avait des scénarios il est producteur il
faut qu'il fasse avancer le programme
hors jeu ne justifie pas qu'il faille
vous pousser dans les bras des uns et
des autres mais il voit là ils ont ils
ont un calva ils savent très bien que
intel qui feinte elle ou pas et ils
veulent avoir des images et c'est vrai
que si vous étiez c'est vrai que là où
la houle a raison c'est que si les
candidats sont courantes pas dans le jeu
ou son pavois la donne parce qu'il faut
donner évidemment ils vont pas les
garder mais ge nous dire c'est là c'est
la règle un peu de la télé ville aux
accidents qu'on est là et pas
intéressant ils le sortent d'une façon
ou d'une autre bah oui mais si vous êtes
vous avez peu dur il ya une quotidienne
a tourné en 3 ans rêvant en une journée
nous il n'y avait pas à l'époque mais
pas fo coucher avec c'était des
amourettes faut se rapprocher des petits
bisous c'était quand même pas très très
méchante et il n'y a pas à l'antenne
après en plus il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose pourquoi amélie neten été
si bonnes parce qu'effectivement avec
senna ont visé deux temps fou qui est un
peu une engueulade qui se passe quelque
chose elle arrive être absorbées jones
mais réveille-toi c'était rigolo c'est
plutôt la télé y a rien de méchant c'est
si vous arrivez vous êtes un petit peu
calme où les pas d'amour êtes vous d pas
à montrer autre chose bah pardon mais
dans ces cas là pour nous vous dire mais
faut pas faut pas voir la télévision à
vous faire une émission
alors moi personnellement c'était pas
mon cas je pense que +20 j'ai quand même
du caractère j'ai jamais eu de problème
à faire des questions avec des garçons
qui me plaisait bien au contraire j'ai
eu même des histoires par la suite à
cause de ces garçons là où on a exposé
ma vie intime en télé et je trouve ça
n'est pas normal tu as couché avec untel
on va l'exposition qu'en tout cas ici au
sein des missions
qui vous plaisait beaucoup
oui oui d'ailleurs est-ce que vous êtes
célibataire non à new york
[Rires]
parce que je vais vous expliquer vérité
guillaume guillaume à chaque fois qu'il
ya quelqu'un qui lui plaît dans
l'émission et qui rendent et
[Rires]
pas du tout
mais c'est sérieux ouais c'est très
vague allez mon perso
j'ai redit non moi je le trouve très
courageuse moi j'ai toujours condamné la
télé réalité alors non pas parce que je
suis une vieille une guilde aaron mais
juste parce que je trouve que c'est un
milieu totalement malsain et écoeurant
et je vais vous dire je condamne pas du
tout les candidats parce que moi je
comprends très bien que quand on est
jeune après tout on a envie de passer à
la télé a des rêves de gloire de
notoriété d'argent facile pourquoi pas
mais moi j'en veux énormément au prod
qui instruit instrumentalise les gamins
qui vous utilisent kivu format en fait
vous êtes de la soeur de prostitution
moderne télévisuelle
une hésitation
c'est très dangereux pour les jeunes qui
regardent
maison donc on commence à se faire de la
chirurgie à 20 ans on va avoir des 56 on
va avoir la bouche comme ça donc je
pense que c'est dévastateur fait
d'accord avec ce que dit
d'accord je suis hyper d'accord avec toi
géraldine en fait je trouve que c'est
pas ça la télé si vous avez une faire de
la télé au final c'est passe à la télé
parce qu'on dit qu'effectivement tv sur
ouaf ouaf ou gagnent plus oui oui plus
con parce que voilà il ya de la drogue
et de la ja du monde
[Applaudissements]
des séries d'aujourd'hui le char est la
raison le 19 ans il ya eu du racket de
la douane à cela dit
c'est
pas du tout
ici à part ça dispositif de résider ici
ou chez laurent ruquier ou à des
réalités moi j'entends des histoires de
vue sur la télé radio mais l'histoire de
drogue incroyable oui c'est très bien
qu'il ya des choses qui vont pas dans
l'intérêt de tous défendre en revanche
je me fais du côté de la chaîne et du
programme il faut qu'ils aient un
programme après assure c'est de ça et je
viens de comprendre
l'origine un simple l horrible horrible
nourrit aujourd'hui toi ce que tu
conserver
l'autre c'est le rythme est arrêté c'est
une même pas qui c'est
c'est la soeur de béni
au kevin jeunes ont vraiment le statut
sont salis des jeux non alors moi
pourquoi je suis venu ici bon usage des
22 ans donc je suis encore extrêmement
jeune je suis rentrée télé j'avais 20
ans j'aime pas je trouve qu'il ya un
problème au niveau du recrutement c'est
on ne recherche pas assez le passif des
candidats avant de les faire rentrer en
télé moi mon prétendants il a été accusé
six mois plus tard avoir après avoir été
en prétendant de violences conjugales je
les notifier trois fois à la production
jeudi virez moi même et six mois plus
tard il a été accusé de violence
conjugale donc déjà il ya un gros
problème sur les recherches en amont sur
les candidats deuxième chose le sivi
psychologique il héros suivi
psychologique c'est à dire que tu fais
une interview avec quelqu'un qui pose
des questions une personne assez
manipulatrice elle dit ce qu'elle veut
de sa vie elle rentre en télé et ensuite
elle fait ce qu'elle veut il ya ni un
suivi psychologique après l'émission
donc ça veut dire on ne sait pas dans
quel état le candidat il sort s'il a
envie ou pas de refaire de la télé
comment il se sent et ensuite de les
candidats donc emblématique on a pas de
suivi sur le fait que tu aies un
influenceur tu as le devoir de faire
attention à ce que tu dis à ce que tu
fais aux histoires que tu vas peut
provoquer quand j'irai pas de le faire
non non des as 10 mois d un minimum je
dirais pas avant 25 ans de faire la télé
parce qu'on n'est pas on n'a pas assez
d'expérience et sans rappel du lycée à
lui à une gamine de 18 ans qui va les
faire de la télé qu elles s'exposent
équivalent espèces en maillot de bain
c'est dégueulasse et moi je vous le dis
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai pris
énormément de maturité avec la télé j'ai
pris énormément d'expérience là mois de
deuil à 2 ans est la moins d'aujourd'hui
mais je le dis mais comment j'ai fait
pour pour accepter ça pour accepter
qu'on me il ya des productions qui ont
aussi et ça je précise dans ma deuxième
télé une production qui faisait des
bandes sons qui coupait des mots qui
prenait d'autres sosies tv de moi et
qu'il me faisait des phrases que je
n'avais jamais dit de ma vie qui
détruisait mon image qui détruisait mon
image c'est pour moi c'est un système
qui est ultra malsain sens mieux pour
les gens qui ont envie de s'exposer se
dénigrer et de passer pour des débiles
excusez moi mais c'est le terme moi je
suis désolé je suis quelqu'un de jeudi
qui a fait un bac s genève on n'a jamais
su que j'étais une fille intelligente ça
n'est vraiment on a tant déçu j'ai fait
des études en bio j'ai fait une école de
mode on ne voit pas ça à la télé c'est
vrai que c'est comme ça et c'est parce
atteindre
ça c'est horrible de reporter ou encore
là je le fais très souvent avec isabelle
morini-bosc dans la soirée quant à lee
et moi quand j'étais comestibles syrie
que c'est un montage voilà un making
c'était quand même bénéfique pour vous
la méritez vous êtes devenus connus vous
êtes devenir chanceuse vous gagnez très
bien potassé vrai que plein de gens pour
des raisons que j'ai créé mon image
c'est ce que faisait cracher dans la
soupe un police alors je vous explique
ça c'est dans la soupe jamais de la vie
parce que je vous explique je me suis
battu j'ai eu du harcèlement dans ma
deuxième télé de la production qui
cautionnait ça je me suis battu coûte
que coûte ils me mentait il me mène plus
les inquiète pas avec nous ces
différentes inquiète pas en train passe
attaqué par le cash a failli retomber
dedans aujourd'hui c'était ma dernière
télé si ni g vu ce que j'avais à voir
mais j'ai mal et aujourd'hui je prend
justement cette visibilité là que j'ai
eu en pourparlers et pour agression
comment vous dire que la télé réalité en
rien de rires eh ben c'est pas que si je
regrette mais si j'avais fait autrement
j'aurais directement imposer les règles
et j'aurais directement john vous aurez
par contre aurillac les est réservé à la
dernière intervention oui bonsoir
bonsoir le truc c'est qu'actuellement la
télé réalité tout ça c'est très à la
mode alors on peut se dire c'est le
revenu à la mode voilà c'est fini si
c'est là la moquette ravin au frère mais
dans le sens où on peut se dire c'est le
revers de la médaille vous avez des
chances pour les citer mais vous gagnez
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent entendu des
gens dire
ça vous intéresse ou non non non on
conçoit non mais c'est vrai nous aide à
le film de cyril vadi l'asie mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est non on peut se
dire qu'actuellement c'est le revers de
la médaille parce que vous gagnez
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent moi je me
demande en revanche
pas dans quelques temps quand il y aura
plus tout la télé réalité tous ces gens
n'a en fait vous être cramé qu'est-ce
que vous avez droit toujours jamais y
aura toujours des célébrités alors ils
auront ils seront plus aussi bankable
mais ces gens-là ils sallefranque le
trésor américain vendra des pastèques à
durban alors personnellement ces gens là
mais c'est vrai alors il faut se poser
la question pour tout le monde
la revue sera fin bien sûr grande des
trucs qu'est ce qu'elle a et voilà après
enchères ça ils veulent encore donner de
moi et me faire faillite
et a bouché à boucher la vue
concrètement chacun donc sa personnalité
chacun suit son chemin et ça c'est une
chose par exemple j'ai pas attendu
quelques mois moi j'ai déjà une
compagnie de compagnies sur lesquels je
travaille à une compagnie de hussein et
de textiles 100% vie gamme si moi je
suis à fond dans l'est dans l'excès
d'eau mais l'année prochaine je vais
sortir une crème solaire qui n'affectait
pas les océans chacun fait son propre
chemin selon ce qu'il a envie de faire
mais après tant pis pour eux il a voulu
profiter du système et hésitations il
faut prendre ce qu'il apprendra l'info
bref est ce que dit toujours benjamin et
il a bien raison voilà il a raison mais
il faut vivre au jour le jour me
carpediem canaux
merci quoi non j'ai dit l'image aimé
lamentable c'est pas la vraie vie en
plus avec tous ces scandales pour
raconter cette incitation à la débauche
c'est scandaleux scandaleux